[Aplausos]
[Música]
qué onda todavía si bien soy mango
gutiérrez tengo 22 años y hago muchas
cosas soy comediante de stand hablo
cultura nacional actriz de doblaje doy
clases y hasta incluso leo manos guarda
igualmente lo que más llama la atención
cuando yo me presento es cuando digo que
soy vegana
yo puedo ver sus caras hay mucha gente
que cree que nosotros somos los raros o
los extremos de la sociedad hay gente
que cree que venimos de otro planeta o
que incluso nacimos con el privilegio de
poder ser así la realidad es que no hoy
que es muy poca la gente que nace
siéndolo esto es más bien una
deconstrucción que una vez que empezamos
a transitar ese camino no hay vuelta
atrás
a los 8 años fue la primera vez que
sentí amor genuino hacia otro ser y fue
con mi perro seus de la foto se ve
[Música]
yo realmente lo amaba y esta es la
prueba fehaciente es un post en facebook
que por si no lo ven dice bebé no
recuerdo muy bien en qué año perdón la
falta de ortografía te me fuiste pero
sólo sé que te extraño muchísimo todavía
me acuerdo cuando te prometí que nunca
iba con be corta a amar más a li lu mi
otro dato como te ame a voz y lo sigo
cumpliendo te amo te amo más que a todos
los animales son mi razón para existir
gracias por la infancia que me hiciste
pasar te amo zeus la romántica
esa vez fue la primera vez que
experimenté sentir amor hacia otro ser
vivo pero una vez según mi perro muere y
yo me empecé a cuestionar un montón de
cosas que llevan desde el lado de la
religión yo era muy católica desde chica
y empecé pero por supuesto a esa edad a
preguntarle a dios por qué te llevaste a
mi perro que te hizo de malo porque se
fue y automáticamente también eso me
hizo empezar a pensar que había un
montón de cosas con el catolicismo
camino me cuadraba no no iban conmigo
entonces empecé a investigar acerca de
otros modos de vida de creencias de fe
de religión y me di cuenta de que lo que
más se amoldaba a mis principios y
convicciones era el budismo si bien no
veneraban y oraban y le rezaba a la
figura del wood a lo que tiene que ver
con sus que las creencias se adaptaban a
mí y entonces decidí llevar esta
filosofía de vida de todas maneras me
sentía bastante perdida en este mundo en
este flash espiritual y me acordé de que
tenía una amiga que también andaba un
poco en esta y
vamos a juntarnos es la excusa perfecta
para hablar y también aprender más y
fuimos a comer yo en ese momento me pedí
lo que acostumbraba a comer siempre que
iba a algún lugar que era una
hamburguesa tamaño dinosaurio con
panceta huevo frito cheddar lechuga
tomate papas fritas todo
en ese momento mi amiga me mira muy
desconcertada yo por dentro tipo huevos
ya sé que como un montón pero tampoco
para que me mires así mi señora no es
que no entiendo vos sos budista si comes
carne
yo realmente no entendía la conexión que
tenía que ver mi creencia religiosa con
mi alimentación no había un punto de
unión y ahí ella me dice claro porque la
base del budismo es entender que hay que
renunciar a generar sufrimiento y bosch
a la hora de comer carlistas financiando
una industria que genera eso y aparte
está en eso en tu plato' un ser que no
eligió morir
ese momento fue como de una birra y man
in that show
además fue una explosión mental de decir
ok tiene razón pero qué voy a hacer
porque no sé qué onda los nutrientes
serán más caros será rico y aparte yo no
entendía nada no sabía cocinar no tenía
idea cómo reemplazar nutrientes y demás
y en un momento me vi en una dicotomía
de decir ok
tiene razón quiero ser vos es dejar la
carne pero al mismo tiempo necesitaba
algo realmente impactante y explícito
para decir bueno por lo menos me hago
vegetariana porque el veganismo era es
para mí en ese momento extremo e
inconcebible
decidí ver vídeos de mataderos muy
explícitos muy fuertes animales
picaneados golpeados degollado dos
torturados y dije ok
no quiero financiar nunca más esta
industria y tome el gran paso para mí
que fue ser vegetariana
para mí era el paso porque por fin me
había decidido a tomar este estilo de
vida y después me duró cinco meses y
después lo empecé a investigar y hey qué
onda la industria láctea la industria de
los huevos de la miel y era lo mismo el
ternero separado de la madre desde el
momento en el que nace para que esa
leche que va para él vaya a consumo
humano lo mismo con gallinas modificadas
biológicamente para que produzcan más de
lo que pueden y era el mismo círculo de
tortura esclavitud y matanza en ese
momento dije ok voy hacer vegana no sé
como decidí llevar una alimentación
basada en plantas sin saber nada y para
mí la alimentación era milanesa de soja
y fideos y si variaba era milanesa de
soja y ensalada nada más por supuesto
que era súper monótona y aburrida pero
también era peligrosa porque eso no te
aporta ninguna cantidad significativa de
nutrientes y de hecho me pasó que me
empecé a sentir mal me mareaba entonces
tenía dos opciones seguían es hasta
quedar anémica que me dijeran tenés que
volver a comer carne
o era responsable con mi alimentación me
informaba y consultada con un
profesional para poder ser responsable y
tener una alimentación adecuada
obviamente es lo que hice de todas
formas después entendí que el veganismo
trasciende la alimentación no es
solamente eso sino que es un estilo de
vida que busca rechazar o reducir el
sufrimiento lo mayor posible no sólo en
alimentación sino también en
entretenimiento en cosmética en
medicamentos y etcétera
a la par también comprendí el concepto
especismo que es una especie de
discriminación moral al igual que el
sexismo o el machismo pero esta es la
discriminación por especies o sea
presumir que los intereses de la especie
humana son mayores y más importantes que
los de otra especie o sea que nosotros
como humanos valemos más que los
animales y por eso se justifica la
opresión y la explotación
fui vegana y ya hace cuatro años que
tome este estilo de vida que es
fascinante porque me cerró por todos
lados estaba haciendo estoy siendo
compasiva con otros seres estoy ayudando
al medio ambiente porque reduzco mi
huella de carbono en los gases de efecto
invernadero que se producen
principalmente por la industria ganadera
también uso productos sustentables que
ayudan muchísimo y además cuido mi salud
porque tener una dieta organizada y
planificada basada en plantas ayuda a
reducir el riesgo por ejemplo de
enfermedades cardiovasculares colesterol
y también ciertos tipos de cáncer
estas cosas por ejemplo yo estoy
comiendo ahora pero que están caras
eso todo esto es vegano y todo esto
super tentador está hecho a base de
cosas del reino vegetal legumbres
cereales frutas verduras entonces cuál
es la excusa
como vegana también descubrí que la
mejor manera y la manera más eficiente
de reforzar esta convicción es haciendo
activismo el activismo tiene la misión
de alentar inspirar y ayudar a otras
personas a que viven a este estilo de
vida y como activista me ha tocado ir a
por ejemplo vigilias que tienen el
objetivo de ir en grupo a puertas del
matadero para visibilizar
audiovisualmente cuál es la realidad de
los animales puertas adentro que es
fuerte pero necesario pero también como
activista me ha pasado de ir a activismo
más agradables como por ejemplo
santuarios que son lugares donde hay
animales libres de rescatados de la
explotación animal que van a estar
libres por el resto de sus vidas como
por ejemplo está cabra
me mato la espalda pero fue un lindo
momento
y entonces ahí fue que reivindiquen lo
que sentí por mi perro seus a los 8 años
ningún animal quiere vivir con una vida
de tortura de explotación solamente por
20 minutos de placer sensorial por
tenerlo en nuestro plato es innecesario
y además comprendí que la única
diferencia en nuestra percepción un
perro es lo mismo que una cabra una vaca
lo mismo que un gato es lo mismo todos
son animales todos quieren jugar quieren
sentirse queridos son como vos son como
yo entonces lo que te invito es ampliar
tu círculo de afecto para comprender que
todos somos animales y que si de verdad
quieres sentir empatía si de verdad
quieres hablar de paz y amor
no tengas violencia en el plato si
rechazas la violencia no las financias
mata a tu zombie que te mantuvo a
anestesiado por mucho tiempo sácate la
venda de los ojos hace la conexión y no
te comas a tu perro muchas gracias
[Aplausos]